venons en à peine n'importe qui au
hasard juppé à rien
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle j'appelle kaka j'appelle
quelqu'un qui voulait que j'appelle
j'appelle quelqu'un comme ça au hasard
macron non
[Musique]
allez tu l'appelles on appelle je vais
appeler qu'il est malin donc manon malik
bentalha à me frapper quelqu'un de
sérieux genre oui 5e sérieux à 37 way
sera pas content chaîne j'arrêterai
rivaz patron de rtl
gérald brice viret dirait une école on a
dit quelqu'un de sérieux mais des codes
tout aura beaucoup plus souple et non
mais on appelle le patron oui on appelle
on a peu qui brice viret wii ou bien
francs capitaux
ah oui vraiment france est peut-être en
train de regarder les deux légendes lui
nous regarde pas son nom alors je vais
vous dire si regarder la chaîne ce soir
les deux sens de l'humour excuse moi tu
vas faire des quotas
parce que la pépite à souhait tout le
monde l'a attaquée sur eilat en train de
faire chier tout le monde serre il a
rythmé moyenne de nhl fogiel non
millions il à l'antenne anconina annoncé
venez d heure
faut toujours prendre un air excéder
pour le faire chez vous appelez des gens
et vous faites play-offs est léchée vous
réponds pas ce matin a annoncé le patron
non ils répondent pas ce génial de mec
sinon il me répond pas alors oui vous
voulez dire que l'on sait faire que ça
les regarde pas et que 3 il en a rien à
[ __ ] un maillot lors des sanctions
mais je l'adorent en plus ses coups
s'est élancé adore mais lille vient
d'être licencié je les adore bon on
appelle vous me dit préférer aller
briller le big boss de cannes au brésil
en lui la suture à temps abba appietto
va être content mais non c'est vrai des
excuses moi si tu veut [ __ ] la merde
alors attendez on va appeler donc bris
j'irai alors et sinon qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire ah ouais moi j'ai fait était
alors oui c'est vrai alors oui ne vous
ai pas fini mais ça fait deux heures à
regarder d'autres à l'eau francky mais
qui passa à nos francs qui m'était pas
ça j'entendais bahia trop sur moi à ce
qu'il paraît je cours après mais ça va
pas mais tu es paris tu croyais quoi le
monde et ses poses croyez quoi quand je
serai plus jamais je pourrais tu
affiches et franck mais c'est pas mon
délire
d'après les rues main tu m'as eu dans
ton lait
[Applaudissements]
francky on à l'antenne oui on est en
impro frank g fontaine franck c'est quoi
le prime ce soir à baby sittor avec vin
diesel
ah ouais je serai là été gravement
touchés par la crise est là
[Rires]